the next Supreme Court justice could
have a major impact on the future of
affirmative action the Trump
administration yesterday rolled back
Obama era guidelines that encourage
schools to consider race as a factor in
admissions the Justice Department will
now promote what is called a race
neutral approach Paula Reed is here with
a look at the implications Paula good
morning good morning the new guidance
focuses on merit in admissions decisions
now critics fear without considering
race school diversity will suffer the
Supreme Court narrowly ruled in 2016
that schools can use race as a factor in
admissions it's a policy of the Obama
administration encouraged but the Trump
administration believes the Obama
guidelines were unnecessary and
overstepped the Constitution this new
policy from the Trump administration
does not change any law on affirmative
action of course only Congress can
change the law but schools can use this
guidance to defend themselves in
lawsuits
what do we know of the timing on this
announcement well this came out
yesterday the day before a holiday
buried in a press release around 4:00
p.m. so clearly they didn't want to make
too big a splash but this is very much
expected they signaled that they would
likely go after this particular issue
when the Attorney General announced that
he was investigating Harvard University
for possible admissions bias against
Asian American and white students and
again this is all part of what happens
between a lot of administration's from
different parties you kind of undo what
the previous administration does we have
to remember civil rights were such a
priority for the Obama Justice
Department yeah an attorney general SEF
sessions has specifically targeted those
policies for rollback everything from
police use of force to transgender
rights and here affirmative action well
how does Justice Kennedy's retirement
the announcement of his retirement how's
that likely to impact the future of
Supreme Court case decisions about
affirmative action
well that 2016 case that I mentioned
Kennedy was the deciding vote and that
was a squeaker of a case it's only a
matter of time if where this issue gets
to the Supreme Court again in fact this
announcement may spark the lawsuit that
brings it up there again and if the
president nominates as he is expected to
do someone who is a reliable
conservative who is skeptical of
affirmative action it is very likely
that this will cut the other way next
time the issue goes to the hike
so I think you're gonna see affirmative
action right up there with abortion and
immigration during these confirmation
hearings just few cheering's up at the
quiet all right Paula Reid thanks Paula